I have a bad habit at at talking um the
same way another person is talking so
when I'm with white people like in
school I did this big in school in high
school yeah like my y friends a black
dude yeah totally bro like yeah I'd be
all the [ __ ] hello white when you're
on your and you're like hey man what's
up dude dah like I would laugh my ass
off if you did that if you went into a
Vietnamese market and used watching guys
I always something was going on right
when you walk into a supermarket what
the hell guy if you have water here I
don't know maybe if I come here to get
the water yeah yeah I did that I do that
a lot like specially with my grandma
like because she speaks Spanish if she
so the only way we communicate is if I
go to her level of English yeah you know
I'm saying so [ __ ] like did you eat do
you ain't nothing okay coming in to meet
me okay you know I'm like no well that's
okay I turn we just met we compromise
with me in the middle I do that all the
time - yeah be okay think anything I
love you I love you throw a lot yeah
they call that [ __ ] there's a term for
it's like you're switching or some [ __ ]
like that
so everybody does that yeah do it I mean
yeah you notice like when there's like
everyone else turns black and stuff yeah
you start is the pewte and it's funny
that people do that with me why people
think I'm black and they'll start doing
that they'll just be like man oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah beer like
that shit's crazy like they'll just say
like random lines you don't mean they're
black it's lit you know what I was like
no think you're talking my bit yeah it's
funny because um you know I grew up in
Sacramento California right so like
Sacramento so my parents on a black
piece blast or so but I cope in a
predominately black area so it's it was
it was weird when I was trying to get
job in Asian thing yeah it's a Korean
thing
okay so like I would I would switch I
would try to get jobs but then people
would hear the way that I speak and it
would deter me from getting a job
because I couldn't hear what they were
here at so when I was speak I would hear
I'm like this is my wife voice right
yeah but to then that's not a white
voice they hear that little toy I have
to sound like this yeah I had a low
number one how to slow down when I speak
and I also had to learn how to enunciate
my words a lot you have too much rhythm
too so I used to get a tape recorder and
record myself speaking and I'm like and
I would hear myself speak and I'm like
because that's not what I was listening
to yeah it might group of friends I
thought I was the proper one yeah you
know yeah so it was it was such a weird
thing how people perceive who you are
yeah Mike specifically - there's like
these couple of Asian youtubers like
when I first met them like they grew up
they clearly never had a black front
another life right and right when he's
talked to him in like you know was good
man I'm like I don't even talk like that
man yeah yeah yeah what are you seeing
right there yeah open a white
neighborhood why you why did he talk
like that
yeah I don't get it yeah I grew up in a
pretty black and Mexican neighborhood
and when I moved to an Asian
neighborhood they're like you sound
black yeah like oh [ __ ] right yeah I'm
like okay how do I I don't want to sound
like them because they sound like they
just got off the boat and then they pick
up a Mexican accent yeah cause I mean
UCLA
all the Asians out there like they sound
like cholos but then they're they have
Asian accents so it's it's the weirdest
way to speak yeah so I mean yeah so we
had to we had to kind of learn how to
speak English again when we got to
college because I couldn't use the
edward anymore i didn't know that [ __ ]
yeah sacramento everybody uses it
so because it's such a culturally
diverse area that you know it was just
like a term of endearment right so I
grew up saying it our whole [ __ ]
lives whether the college that should
switch fast and I didn't know the
negative connotation that it had when
people were there bro I didn't [ __ ]
about one clue room yeah and so like if
you go to Sacramento or the Bay Area in
general till this day you hear everybody
use that word yeah right and so for me
like it'll slip out every now but end
there type in it online and stuff either
or like
talking about it in video he's like like
so like in high school like you know a
lot of my my black friends were like yo
why don't why don't you talk like us and
yeah what do you mean and then like they
would call me you know they would give
me like names like young grasshopper and
then like another nickname that I had
was [ __ ] knees oh there goes [ __ ]
knees right there I'm Japanese and like
yeah and then he's like oh you're not
like the other guys so they would call
me these names and I'm like all right I
thought it was like cool like his friend
well I didn't know like it meant like
mean you heard it in music and
everything yeah yeah and I think back
then too at least the black people that
I was around or the community that I was
around they didn't seem bothered by it
but then now it seems like not
everyone's cool with it I just stay away
right I stay away cuz they're in place
like I'm not 17 anymore
exactly change the way you speak yeah
yeah no for sure yeah sure
cuz I always tell this story to where I
remember the first time I even used the
word it was when there was cat and my
parents store and so back in the day
there used to be this place called oh no
I think you actually met a cat so
there's usually speed this a food truck
almost called mosrite no that had like
these tacos whatever these is something
also the [ __ ] yeah every Friday they
would I [ __ ] you not
Mose would come through he would have a
bunch of food it's a block party every
[ __ ] Friday yeah and I said you not
do it right at my parish store they
would just put up this piece of car
before that it happened they were
shooting dice next or that yeah that's
what the neighborhood thing was every
[ __ ] win weekend Thursday Friday and
Saturday
yeah and so I remember when I was a kid
there's this dude that used to be
chillin there and he used to always come
up to me and talk to me about sports or
whatever and he he told me how to use
taught me how to use the word right so
he was just like yo what do you call me
man and I'm like I don't I don't know
what the call you say say I'm your
[ __ ] right yeah from there not I just
used that word constantly yeah that dude
specifically taught me how to use that
one
you tell people that I'm your [ __ ]
yeah okay children man yeah but that's
just like the language that we grew up
like there was even this spot in the
corner we call it Punjab right yeah
Kapoor jabs my whole life I thought the
liquor stores called poon jabs but it's
just a racially derogatory term for food
job'
no idea because the whole neighborhood
called up yeah yeah so like no you're
gonna get that's true you don't know you
don't know especially when you're a kid
yeah I I didn't know what it meant
I thought it meant friend because all
the kids in the elementary school and
then like yeah that's I mean you know
you grow up in you you you you
understand what it means in your oh [ __ ]
yeah this whole time right no I had no I
I went out first day I'll say I'll say
Nick but I'll just say Rico what I'm
Nick did you know what it meant
no no I did not that's what I'm saying I
didn't know that it was a bad thing you
know I mean I did I did recognize that
black people said it yeah you know I'm
saying yeah so that was that was a thing
of like I wanted you know I said I would
say that was more of like a prominent
black school yeah yeah that was that's
what we're doing we played basketball
before school started at the in the
tennis course and that's what it was all
over there you know whooping you know
yeah that's all it was and it's
interesting cuz now it's like I think
when you're a younger person you really
don't got an excuse now cuz you should
know the cultural yeah yeah yeah yeah a
little different and everyone was online
everyone's online now you can learn so
much faster about the world like if you
if you kind of live like in the hood and
whatever that's your access to the world
yeah you don't know nothing else
right and then so you know if you're
just surrounded by like black kids and
they speak a certain way and that's how
you learned English yeah you just don't
know right you know yeah